MERCY IS IN LA.
BOTH SHIPS ARE RECEIVING
PATIENTS.
JOINING ME NOW, GENERAL TERRENCE
OWEO’SHAUGHNESSY, COMMANDER OF T
UNITED STATES GONE COMMAND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOIN
MING.
I’LL LET -- JOINING ME.
I’LL LET YOU GET RIGHT BACK TO
WORK.
I CAN’T BELIEVE WHAT YOU GUYS
ARE DOING, BUILDING THESE
HOSPITALS, SHIPPING SUPPLIES.
I SAW YOU GUYS JUST INTERCEPTING
A RUSSIAN JET ENTERING ALASKA
AIR SPACE AND TURNED IT AWAY AND
EVEN SENDING SOLDIERS DOW TO
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND JUST
EXPLAIN TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
EVERYTHING YOU’RE DOING.
>> WELL, THANKS, JESSE.
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HIGHLIGHT THE
THINGS THAT THE U.S. NORTHERN
COMMAND AND REALLY OUR ENTIRE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE ARE DOING.
AND YOU STARTED JUST RIGHT, OUR
FIRST OBJECTIVE IS TO DEFEND OUR
HOME LAPPED AND SO WE MAKE SURE
WE HAVE THE FORCE WE NEED 100%
OF THE TIME, 24/7, 365, EVEN
WHILE WE’RE IN THIS VIRUS, WE
MAKE SURE WE’RE READY TO RESPOND
TO ANYTHING.
WE HAVE THAT DONE, WE’RE READY
TO GO.
AT THE SAME TIME WE’RE PROVIDING
SUPPORT ALL ACROSS THE NATION
BECAUSE OUR NATION NEEDS US.
THIS IS A WHOLE NATION APPROACH,
WHOLE OF AMERICA APPROACH.
WE’RE PART OF IT.
WE GOT THE HOSPITAL SHIPS, WE
GOT ARMY HOSPITALS THAT ARE
BUILT UP IN THE JAVITS CENTER IN
NEW YORK CITY, WE’RE DOING THE
SAME THING IN SEATTLE.
WE’RE BRINGING STUFF DOWN TO NEW
ORLEANS, TO DALLAS AND WE’RE
POSTURED TO BRING EVEN MORE.
WE ARE PART OF THIS FIGHT.
OUR COMMANDER IN CHIEF DECLARED
A WAR ON COVID AND WE’RE
TREATING THIS LIKE A LARGE
MILITARY CAMPAIGN.
JESSE:  I KNOW YOU GUYS PLAN FOR
EVERYTHING BUT DID YOU GUYS WAR
GAME THIS THING OUT OR IS THIS
JUST ON THE FLY?
>> WELL, I’LL TELL YOU WHAT,
JESSE.
AMERICA WANTS US PLANNING FOR
THE WORST THINGS.
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT WE’RE DOING.
WE’VE BEEN PART OF THIS ALL THE
WAY SINCE THE PRESIDENT MADE
THAT IMPORTANT DECISION TO
RESTRICT FLIGHTS FROM CHINA AND
WE WERE PART OF BRINGING THE
AMERICAN CITIZENS HOME AND
QUARANTINING THEM IN SOME OF OUR
MILITARY BASES AND SOME OF THE
FOLKS ON THE CRUISE LINERS, WE
WERE ABLE TO HOUSE THEM BECAUSE
AMERICAN CITIZENS NEEDED US.
WE ARE TRYING TO STAY ONE STEP
AHEAD OF THEM.
WE’RE GOING TO BE THERE WHEN THE
NATION NEEDS US.
JESSE:  WE HAVE A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE IN YOU GUYS.
WE OWE YOU A HUGE DEBT OF
GRATITUDE.
IT’S ASTOUNDING WHAT YOU GUYS
CAN ACCOMPLISH IN SUCH A SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME.
LAST QUESTION BEFORE I LET YOU
GO.
I KNOW THIS IS A BIOLOGICAL
WARFARE.
WE HAVEN’T COME TO THAT
CONCLUSION, INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES DON’T BELIEVE IT IS.
THINKING AHEAD YEARS FROM NOW,
OUR ENEMIES HAVE TO SEE THAT
THIS REALLY BROUGHT THIS COUNTRY
TO ITS KNEES.
ARE WE PREPARED FOR OUR ENEMIES
TO PUT TOGETHER A BIOLOGICAL
AGENT THAT YOU CAN EASILY SNEAK
INTO THE COUNTRY, JUST THROUGH
HUMANS, THEY SHAKE A BUNCH OF
HANDS, COUGH ON A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE AND HERE WE ARE AGAIN,
SHUTTING THE WHOLE ECONOMY DOWN.
HOW DO YOU PREVENT THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK JESSE YOU
CERTAINLY HIT AN IMPORTANT POINT
AND I THINK AS HORRIFIC AS THIS
IS, THIS IS GOING TO HELP
AMERICA PREPARE FOR THE FUTURE,
THE WHOLE OF AMERICA APPROACH IS
EXACTLY THE APPROACH.
WE HAVEN’T SEEN THIS SINCE WORLD
WAR II, THE WAY AMERICA IS
PULLING TOGETHER, WHETHER THE
INTERAGENCIES PULLING TOGETHER,
WHETHER IT’S THE U.S. MILITARY
CONTRIBUTING AT HOME, AMERICA
THEY STAND UP.
WHEN IT’S NEEDED, AMERICA WILL
PULL TOGETHER, WHETHER IT’S
SOMETHING TO GET AFTER COVID-19
OR SOMETHING THAT COMES AT US IN
THE FUTURE.
JESSE:  GENERAL, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
AMERICA THANKS YOU.